كورتوا المراقبه الدائمه للجنه الدوليه
للسالب الاحمر لدى الامم المتحده ورئيسه
بعثه اللجنه في نيويورك تنضم الينا ما
الظروف التي ترافق خروج السودانيين الى
اماكن اكثر امنا سواء داخل السودان او
خارجها
شكرا جزيلا للاستضافه الوضع صعب جدا
والايام العاشره الاخيره من القتال
المحتدم في الاماكن المزدحمه بالناس
المدنيين كان لها اثر عظيم على الناس
الناس اما انهم علقوا في منازلهم وغير
قادرين على الوصول الى الغذاء ومياه الشرب
والرعايه الصحيه
وايضا الدمار بسبب القصف الشديد ايضا عقد
سبيلهم للوصول الى هذه الاماكن
كالمستشفيات وما الى ذلك المستشفيات تاثرت
قدرتها على التقديم العلاج بسبب انعدام
المياه وانعدام القدرات والاطباء لم
يعودوا يذهبون الى هذه المستشفيات لكي
يقدموا الخدمات الاساسيه للشعب ولكن الناس
ايضا يشعرون بالذهول والرعب والخوف بسبب
المعارك التي تجري حتى على مستوى الشوارع
لذلك الناس يشعرون بانهم في حاله خطره
ويحاولون ان يصلوا الى الخدمات الاساسيه
بينما يتم الان تنفيذ الهدنه وذلك لكي
يهتموا بانفسهم وعائلاتهم ويصلوا الى
الاماكن التي فيها
البضائع او الخدمات الاساسيه او الغذاء او
المياه او العلاج وما الامكانيات المتاحه
للمخيمات او اماكن لجوء السودانيين او
نزوحهم الى داخل السودان ما الذي يؤمن لهم
هناك
استدعان
لديه الان وضع انساني معقد حتى قبل اندلاع
العنف ثلاثه ملايين شخص الان في دارفور
شردوا
في اماكن اخرى في البلاد ايضا وايضا مليون
شخص كانوا يسعون للجوء الى السودان من دول
مجاوره بسبب العنف في تلك البلدان اذا
فهناك اناس هم الان في وضع صعب جدا وهش
للغايه هم ايضا
يواجهون عبئا اضافيا
لانه كان عليهم ان ينتقلوا ويفروا من
اماكن التوتر والصراع التي هي تندلع ليس
فقط في الخرطوم ولكن فيها جاء اخرى من
البلاد والناس ذهبوا لللجوء الى اي مكان
عن طريق العبور عبر الحدود او الانتقال
خارج الخرطوم الى
اماكن اخرى في السودان بطريقه سريعه جدا
بسبب كثافه المعارك هل استطعتم صيدله من
الاستفاده من ساعات الهدن او وقفه اطلاق
النار
وان كانت نسبيه في مناطق معينه
ساعيد السؤال هل تمكنتم كلجنه الدوليه
الصليب الاحمر لايصال المساعدات
استفاده من ساعات وقف اطلاق النار او
الهدن التي كانت نسبيه
اللجنه الدوليه للصليب الاحمر
وزملائها ومن يعملون معها يحاولون العمل
على قدم وساق وهم ككل الموظفين الانسانيين
يحاولون ان
يذهبوا وان يكونوا مع الناس في ملاجئهم
وفي الايام الاولى لم يستطيعوا التجاوب
ولكن في الوقت ذاته كنا نحاول القيامه
بالتواصل باقصى قدر ممكن زودنا مستشفيين
بمعدات طبيه في
دارفور ونامل للهدنه ان تساعدنا على تقييم
الحاجات ووضع الاولويات لدعم المستشفيات
وذلك لضمان ان المواد الاساسيه يتم
توزيعها الى هذه المستشفيات وايضا لكي
تقوم المستشفيات بوظائف وخاصه فيما يتعلق
بعلاج الجرحى لكي يكون هناك التجاوب مع
الحالات الطارئه ولكن الوضع كان صعبا جدا
على فرقنا فيما يتعلق بالتحرك وايضا قمنا
بالعمل مع الاطراف للسماح لنا باعطائنا
الحيز الانسانيه لكي نتحرك ونقدم
الاستجابه الضروريه اذا فنحن نقوم بزياده
جهودنا استنادا الى المعلومات التي تصلنا
لكي نعمل فور ان تصلنا الضمانات الامنيه
لكي نقدم الخدمات الضروريه والطارئه للناس
في حال استمرت هذه المعارك وهذا النزاع ما
هي الخطه الموضوعه على المدى القصير
صيدلتيتيا
قصتنا على المدى القصير هي ان نقوم وفوريا
بمعالجه احتياجات المستشفيات وكما اشار
زميلي من منظمه الصحه العالميه الكثير من
المستشفيات غير قادره على تلبيه الحاجات
فالحاجات هي اكثر من سعتهم وقدراتهم اذا
يجب ان نساعدهم فورا ايضا الاولويه الاخرى
هي تقديم واستعاده منشات المياه والكهرباء
ونقل فرق الصيانه لكي يقوموا باصلاح هذه
الخدمات الاساسيه التي تسمح للمستشفيات
بالقيام بوظائفها نحن قلقون ايضا بشان
العائلات التي فصلت افراد عن بعضها البعض
بسبب العنف المحتدم والكثيرون فقدوا
احبتهم ولم يدروا يعودوا يعرفون اين هم
لذلك يجب ان نعيد لم شمله م اذا فالتواصل
بين العائلات يعتبروا احدى اولوياتنا
القصوى
المراقبه الدائمه للجنه الدوليه للسالب
الاحمر لدى الامم المتحده